welcome back new data out this week is
confirming what we do all along school
lockdowns have had a devastating impact
on our kids education
federal testing numbers from the
department of education show that over
the last two years reading and math
scores have suffered the steepest
decline we've seen in decades
look at this
the average scores for fourth graders
have dropped five points in reading
and seven points in math since the start
of covet 19 in the lockdowns
this is the biggest decrease we've seen
in reading in 30 years and it's the
deepest year over year decline in math
scores on record
these numbers are indeed alarming
but they're part of an even more
alarming trend proficiency in reading
and math
they've been on a downward slide for
better part of a decade
and kovid made it worse
school lockdowns crushed students
ability to learn
and no one had a bigger role in keeping
schools closed than the president of the
american federation of teachers randy
weingarten
she found she fought tooth and nail for
kids and teachers to stay at home as
long as possible
and now she's rewriting history
given
the effects of that disruption do you
have any regrets for not advocating in a
more strong fashion for a faster return
to in-person learning
so this is where i'm going to really
disagree with you i mean i was
i
personally i have been pushing for the
return to in-person learning since april
of 2020. could we overcome all the fear
i wish we could have
but i don't think it's anybody's fault
that we didn't understand what was going
on in terms of schooling
april of 2020 it's a flat out lie
and lucky for us
we have the tape to prove it randy and
her teacher union friends had zero
interest in returning to the classroom
we have an obligation to make remote
better because until we can really
decrease community spread throughout the
united states
distance learning and distance
working is going to be a fact of life
the reason we raised the issue about as
a last resort on a local basis a strike
a safety strike action is because we're
really concerned as schools start
opening in august that you got the
deniers and you got the magical thinking
we know that kids need in-person
learning and that remote instruction is
no substitute for it
but it has to be safe
so she said she's been fighting for it
since april of 2020. all of those clips
are from july and august of 2020. we
have the receipts they say they're all
about protecting the kids
but if these people really wanted to
make schools safer so kids could return
to the classroom
they would have actually spent i don't
know the money designated for
coveted changes in schools to make it
easier to reopen
i mean isn't that what they say they
want it all along more money
well get this
of the 122 billion in federal money set
aside for schools
barely over 15 billion has been spent
that means almost 90 of the coveted
money is untouched
i'm sure they'll spend the remaining 100
billion very wisely how many diversity
equity and inclusion advisors and
counselors can you hire for that
and it gets worse they're not taking any
responsibility for the damage they've
caused instead
they're passing the blame on to somebody
else and you know who they're blaming
here's what education secretary miguel
cardona said this week and i quote
today's data confirmed the significant
impact the prior administration's
mismanagement of the pandemic has had on
our children's progress and academic
well-being we must repair the damage
done by orange man bad donald trump's
mismanagement of the pandemic and we
will
what world are these people living in
donald trump said over and over again
open the schools
we've got to go to school we've got to
open up we've got to open up our schools
and open up our businesses i want to
just say get open in the fall
we want your schools open children are
at the lowest risk of any age group from
the virus indefinite school closures
will inflict lasting harm to our
nation's children he said what we knew
kids are at the lowest risk surprise
surprise donald trump was right all
along but when we look at the big
picture the damage caused by school
lockdowns is just a small piece of the
puzzle
the slow motion implosion of our
education system is building for decades
we're just now noticing in my book i
called it the covid 1619 moment because
with parents seeing what their kids were
being taught in their zoom classrooms it
became impossible to ignore
public schools more accurately called
government schools are no longer
focusing on teaching kids the essentials
you know reading writing
arithmetic history civics however you
say arithmetic instead they're poisoning
young minds with gender fluidity and
race and sex ed it's sheer
indoctrination in red states and blue
states rich cities and poor cities
government schools and private schools
it's serious stuff you might say it's a
threat to our republic
you can't keep a country if you're
teaching kids to hate that country
the affections and affiliations of our
kids are the target of the left
and now those same kids can't even read
rachel campos duffy is my co-host on fox
and friends weekend and carol markowitz
is a columnist for the new york post
rachel sound off they're admitting that
kids are falling behind but it's donald
trump's fault
yeah they do not get to get away with
gaslighting us on this um fauci biden
wilinski randy weingarten from the union
which you covered well all of them
fought to shut down our schools and not
only did they shut down our public
schools they went after the private
schools the catholic schools they tried
to get them to shut down because they
couldn't have them open proving that no
kids were you know they said kids are
going to die if you keep the schools
open and catholic schools proved that
you could do it and by the way you would
keep the schools open no one's going to
die and by the way they didn't need all
those billions of dollars that you
talked about that are now going to go to
all these diversity and crt programs and
transgender programs in our school they
didn't need that you know who did stay
open pete the chinese 195 million
chinese students went right back to
school in the fall when they were
shutting down our schools and boy the
chinese love this they our kids got you
know their scores went down they got
lazier they got depressed they got
suicidal they got fatter because
childhood obesity went up when you
closed down the schools and locked our
kids up um all of this you couldn't
chairman g couldn't have thought of a
better plan to undermine our future um
and these scores are just one more
example of it well they sent the virus
over to us so it was part of their plan
uh carol real quick is this are they
this
cynical or do they really believe what
they're saying here the democrats
well i think they're absolutely trying
to rewrite history and the timeline is
so important i love that you called out
randy weingarten for wanting to keep
schools closed in 2020 but it's
important to note that she wanted to
keep schools closed in 2021 also and it
wasn't just her secretary cardona joe
biden various governors tons of people
on the left all wanted to keep schools
closed for september 2021 and when
governor desantis my governor in florida
was heading towards opening schools all
the headlines said florida schools open
as cases climb it was a specific motion
to stop florida from opening schools and
they kept schools open and prove that it
was possible all of these democrats want
to pretend that they weren't involved in
this tragedy that we're living through
right now and this travesty with these
scores but they're it's absolutely at
their feet and randy weingarten is
number one
uh person that caused this
and we we knew even then that kids were
not the ones affected rachel real quick
do voters remember this
of course they do and this is why you
talk about this awakening the 1619
moment that you talked about it's not
just what you know was they were
teaching our children but the way they
wanted to torture our children the
parents who had to fight to keep the
schools open to take the mass off
parents are not going to forget this
they don't get to get away with this and
we certainly should keep replaying these
clips as you just done pete um because
sometimes uh they want to rewrite
history we're not going to let them do
it this time yeah and carol you made the
move to say hey we're going to florida
where we we know they will keep it open
in the future rachel carol thank you so
much for your time tonight appreciate it
thank you thank you pete hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else